Um, do it, but, uh, I make fun of like, Oh dude,
Biden. This is what I think about.
I think that the thing about
Bernie and Biden doing the crowd with no crowd doing the
debates with no crowd is bad for Biden because Biden,
when people clap at what he says,
he resets and starts realizing what he's going to say next.
And when that off the cuff,
he just starts talking about whatever somebody said, Hey,
what's up with the coronavirus? And he said in the camera's like, well,
I'm just, you know,
it's a shame that Sanders is siding with Trump and walked into a car
Guys, guys, you know, I don't know, man,
this is what I love too. I'll make fun of whoever any candidate. I don't give a.
And like, you have to make fun of all of them. Right?
You can't just make fun of some of them because that's not cool. And, um,
I made fun of, uh, Trump because he did this thing. Oh, I said,
it's really funny to,
if it will be so hilarious if Trump got the coronavirus and of course funny,
because he said it was a hoax five days ago and he's like,
I don't feel any symptoms wrong. I don't feel any symptoms. Fine.
I don't have it. I don't need to get tested.
So it will be funny if he got the coronavirus. Now, obviously I'm being silly.
Obviously. I don't want people to get the Corona virus.
You know? So.
Some was like, what'd he say, let me just go to the tweets out.
Here we go. It will be so hilarious. If Trump cut the corner of ours,
like so funny and some guy writes, why would it be funny? Explain. And I wrote,
because he kept saying how he didn't need to get tested. He was so shore.
So it would be funny if he actually had it weird. I have to explain that,
but here we are. And then the wrote,
but I'm still just trying to understand why it would be funny if your present
contrast is a serious illness. So I said to the cook, I was being silly,
but you knew that and you still ask me why it was funny. I explained knowing,
you know, now you're asking again, pretending I meant what I said seriously,
when you know, I'm a comedian, you're probably not stupid.
So how come you're acting that way? So the cook said, first of all,
I have no idea who you are now. Fine all by that for the argument,
but you're a boy he's coming up.
Also, you check the profile by now. had
also, even if you didn't know, I was a comedian,
you could assume that I'm not a sociopath with 1 million followers.
And just hoping the president of the United States gets a
deathly disease. Cause he's 70 whatever. And he says, first of all,
I know who I have no idea who you are. Just,
I just saw that your tweet was retweeted by a friend of mine.
Cool.
Second, don't hide behind the label of comedian. The, and that's so big.
That's one of my favorite things. That's one of my favorite things. Oh,
you're hiding behind the label of no, bro. I, uh, well, I'll get to it.
That's so weak. He says, standing on stage with a mic and pandering for clapper.
Doesn't make you a comedian. You have to actually be funny. Okay.
So clap. There is get rid of that obviously,
because I can't see the thing below it. One fire. Um, so clapper is,
we can just say stuff to people will clap, which I don't do. Obviously,
if you've ever been in my shows, any of my shows,
I'm not trying to get clapped.
Or when I'm talking about Cubans asking for directions, Yeti yet.
So I wrote, if you don't know now I'm just breaking it down now.
Just simply breaking it down.
If you don't know who I am, then how on earth do you know what I do on stage?
Now? Let me just, now, here we go. I got to get this going. Here we go.
If you don't know who I am, then,
then how on earth do you know what I do on stage?
I'm not hiding behind, uh, any label.
I'm literally a comedian.
Just.
Because you don't think what I said is funny. Doesn't you?
It doesn't mean it's not.
Let's ask random people who has a better sense of humor. Me or me or you.
I said to the, and then he says,
this is my favorite. And I can't even respond to it because it's awesome.
Um, trust me, dude, I'm way funnier than you.
Anyone who says, trust me, dude, is a
like, it's just, well, you know, but you don't let that, but, but he says,
but don't let that offend you. And then he follows it up with, um,
extremely funny
also lip also liberals are categorically insufferable now
yet painfully unaware of this. So you've also got that working against you,
perhaps you'll all be able to create.
You'll all be able to create quality material again in 2024.
Okay. So look, dude, first of all, you don't know who I am.
You've said that. How do you know I'm.
A liberal? How.
Do you know how far left I am? Because I'm not far left.
And I agree that a lot of far left liberals are extremely
insufferable.
Also.
Most of the most successful, no, this is just a fact.
Most of the most successful comedians are liberal. So,
huh. So I write a,
so I write just, I just retweeted and did the laughing,
crying emoji face because obviously the guy lost his own argument with just
saying all that. But uh, you can't keep arguing with a dumb.
And then I went his page and looked and he had like this video of him
sucking up to Trump. Like he's like I finally met Trump
and like was such a like fan boy.
Imagine being a fan boy to a 74 year.
You know? Um,
I love this world.
Like people like that get to exist and have a platform.
It's so awesome. So I retweeted it.
I'm sure that has mentioned we're busy for a while.
And then he said something like, Oh dude, I've off so many liberals.
That's the other thing too. I'm not, I wasn't making any blanket statements.
You can't just say, Oh all liberals. Like, just like,
I'm not saying all, uh, you know, conservatives,
because I don't think that man.
And I'm out of this liberal, conservative. I'm out of it, dude.
I'm I'm out. You've all it up. I'm out.
I'm Ralph Nader in this, dude. I'm out color me,
green bro. I'm out, man. I'm not in this.
I'm not one way or the other y'all dude.
I'm not crying. And I'm not saying, well, actually I'm not doing that.
I'm out, bro. I just love how Biden was like,
this is the, this is the that just
My running mate will be a woman. He tweets.
And I hate that. He did that because here's the thing, man.
Who cares? What?
Yeah, that's the thing. The guy right under it wrote Democrats. See this.
I don't like when they blanket.
I mean like Democrats only care about stop doing it like this. Just say heat.
I hate that, man. But he is what he writes.
He Democrats only care about what you are. Not who you are.
Why does this guy, Joey? Saldino I don't know who he is.
I'm assuming he's a big Republican,
but why doesn't he realize that that's just going to mobilize,
this is now I don't want anybody mobilizing like,
but he's just, he doesn't realize that that's going to make Democrats be like,
you he'd have more people on his side. Or if he was just like,
Oh the Biden only cares about what you are. Not who you are. So.
My running mate will be a woman.
W D say just fi find out who it is and then tell us, you know,
so I mean, it's so ridiculous to tell them, I wrote, tell us more about her.
Will she be tall, short, brunette, blonde.
Like.
You're trying to be not sexist. You sound in sexist. Also.
You sniff kids.
Um, I don't know.
Trump is just ridiculous. This
David Brent. He did this thing. I, I tweeted it.
It definitely got over the. I can't even believe SOCOM.
[Inaudible].
You got to go on Twitter, Instagram and look at it. He goes like this. Yeah.
They came out with fake news and they found it out. And, but here it is. I said,
Google was a part of it. They said it wasn't, but they are.
I got proof right here. And then just goes point and full and flicks it away,
dude, like it's a bugger and you're driving on the freeway,
dude, the guy is such an.
Unbelievable dude.
How the president just goes,
the president just goes Coby and tosses it out.
Man. Remember when Colby dying was the worst thing. Wow.
That was like a month ago. And now Jesus Christ.
Um.
So insane. I think that's so funny that he did that kind of guy, such a.
And if I they're all, dude,
all also how big
for real, I don't care who you are. How big does your ego have to be?
If you legitimately are running for president,
you have to think, you know how to fix the country,
which is wrong because nobody knows dude.
And probably the people who do know aren't are smart enough to realize they
think they don't know. Anyway, dude, everybody's.